here's the look at yourself in the
mirror question are you really ready
what are some tough questions someone
has to ask themself because we all think
we're ready we wouldn't come here or you
wouldn't whether we grew up here or not
try to do something where we don't think
our ego thinks we're ready but maybe
we're not how do we know it's really
good question how do you know you know
if you're getting the kinds of responses
that you're looking for if people are
interested in you if people want to help
you if if doors are opening for you if
your material again if you're a writer
if your material is blazing hot not this
is like a really good draft I'm gonna do
another one but I'm gonna send out this
one because it's really good I can do
better but this is really good you have
one shot so if your material isn't there
yet I know very smart people who have
fantastic connections but they are not
sending out their material until they
know that it's great until they know
it's blazing hot so if you're not
getting people who want to help you
people who want to open some doors for
you if you're not getting positive
responses then you're probably not ready
yet okay let's take a little bit of a
twist let's suppose you're getting all
these green lights from people but
there's something in you sabotaging it
oh yes do you see that a lot I have seen
it I've absolutely seen it in my book I
talked about a young woman and it was
really sad she um she was a waitress in
Malibu and she was an aspiring actress
and her idol came into the restaurant
where she worked and she happened to be
in her section and this young woman
struck up a conversation with her idol
and her idol said what do you do and she
said I'm an aspiring actress and her her
idol said well you know what I'm
shooting in LA why don't you come and
visit the set tomorrow and the waitress
said oh my god that would be amazed
thank you so much she was so excited she
went out with her friends the night
before she got she drank too much she
set her alarm clock but not for the
right time she woke up hungover she woke
up too late and she totally sabotaged
herself because emotionally she wasn't
ready for it
and it's heartbreaking when you see that
right Howard well what are some things
that you see I mean that's a great
example I've seen people that have done
stuff like that I think a lot of it is
because they're scared yeah but they
don't want to admit it
yes what are some other things that you
can see like oh that's the sabotage sort
of veil working there sure let me think
about that I think if somebody is being
obnoxious or too pushy that is certainly
a way to sabotage yourself if if your
material isn't ready and you're sending
it out if another way to sabotage
yourself is everybody is on social media
all the time if your digital profile is
not professional that's a way to
sabotage yourself I am I once was
looking for to hire an assistant and
this woman had a great resume but I
looked on her Facebook page and her
profile picture was her at a party with
her you know sleeve kind of holding a
red cup and I thought I can't hire this
woman she and she had a great resume but
I wouldn't hire her because she didn't
have she wasn't professional and she
didn't have common sense that you don't
do that let me think of what else it
might be when you don't deliver on what
you say you're gonna do that is a huge
thing if you make promises that you
can't keep
that's totally sabotaging yourself it's
better to undersell and over-deliver